[Musique]
Toulon est coincé entre Nice et
Marseille Toulon c'est une c'est un port
militaire les premiers joueurs de rugby
Toulon étaient des militaires et et
Toulon s'est toujours senti un peu à
l'étroit là-dedans Toulon c'est le bagne
Toulon c'est la peste qui redémarre ici
ça c'est un partout ça redémarre ici
Toulon c'est le sabordage de la flotte
Toulon c'est quand elle se livre aux
Anglais qui est repris par Napoléon donc
il y a tout un tas de traumatisme et
Toulon se retrouve à travers son équipe
de rugby parce que son équipe de rugby
c'est la fierté de la fierté du toulonis
et c'est pour ça qu'il y a autant de
ferveur autant de chaleur et autant
autant des mois aussi parce que le
supporte est très émotif parce que cette
ville a toujours a toujours un peu de
souffrance mais elle a toujours eu
trouvé la force pour se relever toujours
trouvver la force pour avancer toujours
trouver la force pour pour pour rester
forte rester
vivante
[Applaudissements]
est cétait écrit après des années de
purgatoire en de le RBY dev acc 14
l'élite du rugby
hexagonal 14 c'est joie pour la villete
PL de la
[Musique]
ville 2 ans auparavant le destin du club
était bouleversé après avoir fait
fortune dans l'édition de bande dessiné
mour bal rachet le club moribon de la
ville de son enfance à une époque où
partout le rugby se professionnalise il
applique une méthode déée par le milieu
injecter des millions racheter les
meilleurs jouurs monde entier fin de
carrière et proposé à la star Tana omaga
d'entraîner cette équipe de
mercenaire merci
beaucoup merci
beaucoupoupci la saison été très on a
été attaqué de tous les côtés on a on s
battu tous les dimanches avec équipes
quiune idée en tête cétait battre et
malgré C son très difficiles aur été
premier de la première journée à la
dernière on des champions de
France
entre l'édition et le rugby il y a un
parallèle commun qui est le sport il y a
un véritable parallèle qui est dans les
deux cas on fait rêver les gens quand je
fais des livres c'est pour faire rêver
les gens quoi s'ils me disent j'ai j'ai
lu ton bouquin j'ai passé une demi-heure
ou 40 minutes où j'ai oublié mes soucis
voilà c'est mon je suis un faisur de
rêve dans le rugby c'est pas pareil les
gens qui sont là je dire on les fait
rêver la force du rugby c'est d'être un
sport où il se passe le score évolue où
il pe se passer quelque chose à tout
moment il correspond à no besoins de
consommation d'aujourd'hui au foot on
s'enmerde il y a une équipe qui attaque
qui se fait contrer par une équipe qui
défend qui va elle-même attaquer qui va
se faire recontrer ce qu'il y a de bien
dans le foot c'est voir les résumés des
buts quoi je avec le son en direct comme
ça c'est top sinon on s'enmerde pendant
90 minutes pour voir un but quand on
voit un but on pris le ciel c'est super
j'ai vu une action au rugby c'est pas le
cas c'est c'est magnifique le ballon
part dans tous les sens que ça va vite
et que il arrive un joueur qu'on a
jamais dit cru qu'il le mettrait de ce
côté on pensait qu'il mettrait côté
c'est c'est c'est vers ça qu' doit aller
réi vers un vrai spectacle visuel quoi
quand le le pilier avant il a enlevé le
le le maillot il y avait il y avait la
graisse maintenant il y a les tablettes
de chocolat quoi et c'est on va vers ça
quoi ça c'est clair c'est le du du 1 au
15 ce seront des athlètes de véritables
athlètes les valeurs du rugby dans dans
le enfin bien sûr il y a des gens qui
croient que nous après des match on se
on va dans les vestiaires on prend une
douche on se rabille on se dit salut à
la prochaine c'est c'est pas vrai ça se
passe pas comme ça tout on a on a aussi
quand j'entends des présidents dire nous
c'est autre chose il y a des valeurs
entre les hommes on aime être ensemble
et mais nous aussi je dire bien sûr nous
aussi on les a C valeur là aussi mais à
part que c'est pas notre fond de
commerce les valeurs on a un peu de
plusudur làdessus alors des gens non
c'est les seuls c'est le seul fond de
commerce il manque de
plusudur le passage au rugby moderne
avec ses stars et ses paillettes est
trop brutal et sur la rade on se méfie
du style boudgéal ce fils d'immigré ne
respecte rien dans une ville qui est
passée au Front national de 1995 à
2001ie bal quand arrivé c'est vrai que
c'était un peu terrible parce que il est
choquant quoi il est choquant il est il
vit le il vit il vit sa passion quoi il
vit sa passion donc
automatiquement on peut pas lui lever ça
quoi après après c'est sûr qu'il a eu
des propos il a tenu des paroles qui
sont pas connu dans le monde du rugby il
veut
s'imposer il aime Toulon il aime il aime
la ville il aime le redby il le sent le
RBY bon après il est pas connaisseur il
est pas connaiss CER mais ça veut pas
dire qu'il est pénible mais bon à un
moment donné faut bon ben là il a su se
remettre en place il a il a mis un staff
qu'il a voulu avec Monsieur omaga
monsieur catin monsieur Kena et
automatiquement ben c'est que du positif
et maintenant quand il intervient c'est
pas du négatif c'est bien c'est parfait
il dit des vérités il dit des vérités
vraies bah le fait de pas venir du rugby
déjà ça on vous le fait payer assez cher
quoi parce que c'est un c'est un
micromonde he le le rugby à Toulon moi
j'ai aucune histoire donc
systématiquement quand vous vous
permettez la moindre réflexion sur le
jeu sur des joueurs vous êtes pas
crédiible voilà donc ça on vous le fait
payer bon ensuite le fait de de dépendre
d'aucun réseau on vous le fait payer
aussi un peu moi je suis un sputnique
hein à Toulon dire que je je fais pas
mon argent à Toulon j'ai ça représente
0,001 % de mon chiffre d'affaires
j'appartiens à aucun réseau et j'étais à
peu près inconnu quoi alors que j'avais
j'avais une vie qui était vraiment mieux
que maintenant et donc les gens ici ils
aiment bien soit des gens qui
appartiennent dans des réseaux soit des
gens qu'on peut contrôler quoi ce qui
est normal et moi je suis je suis un
cauchemar pour beaucoup de gens et puis
dans ma communication comme j'ai
toujours dit ce que je pensais et que
j'étais pas spécialement consensuel
j'étais j'étais très enfin je me suis
fait taper dessus quoi voilà les gens
qui parlent de valeur là-haut je suis
désolé ils sont en notes de frais quoi
ils sont en notes de frais et c'est pas
des notes de frais dans des hôtels ibis
c'est des notes de frais dans des hôtels
de ha de haut standing
et et l'argent a une importance puisque
puisque ça leur donne un statut un
statut de de dépense qu'il n'auraiit pas
dans leur vie privée quoi bon je le dis
c'est la vérité mais il faut pas le dire
voilà les
on est dans on est dans un club où dans
un système le rugby où où une partie de
l'économie est basée sur le bénévolat
moi dans l'entreprise le bénévolat
j'appelle ça le travail au noir
donc je le dis mais il faut pas le dire
simplement j'essaie de j'essaie de dire
les choses comme je les vois et comme je
les pense et et sans langue de bois quoi
alors on peut me reprocher ce qu'on veut
mais j'ai toujours dit ce que je pensais
dans le rugby il y a de l'argent et il
faut pas le lire moi je le dis voilà les
joueurs il négocient de l'argent il
viennent ici et et tous les joueurs ne
parlent qu'argent ils ne parlent pas
amour du maillot je suis désolé il n pas
un seul qui m'a parlé amour du maillot
ça jamais je l'ai jamais vu quoi il
parle argent il parle quelle voiture
j'aurais quel quel genre de logement
j'aurais est-ce que je peux être
augmenté quelle prime je peux avoir
c'est ça le discours du
[Musique]
joueur peut-être que j'ai trop montré ma
gueule c'est possible aussi
mais pour moi il est très compliqué
souvent d'être dans les tribunes on me
reproche d'être sur le terrain mais les
tribunes c'est invivable pour moi c'est
invivable et euh maintenant je fais
partie du spectacle il y a des gens qui
viennent pour voir ma gueule quand on
prend un essai il y en a aussi qui
voient qui viennent pour voir ma gueule
quand on a marqueur mais je sais que
quand on se prend un essai il y a il y a
plein de gens qui me regardent quoi et
je je je j'entends mais tu as vu tu te
l'ai pris celui-là quoi voilà il m' ton
pognon tu te l'ai pris quand même quoi
et c'est totalement aberérrant
[Musique]
quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était c'était hallucinant les propos
que pouvait tenir les gens et la
haine sur sur moi sur le fait que que
j'ai que j'ai aussi un petit peu
socialement et les insultes que je
prenais quoi sur
là-dessus je vois pas en quoi le fait de
de moi je viens très bas j'ai créé de
l'emploi je payé des impôts pour qu'il y
ait des routes des hôpitaux et une
sécurité tu vois pas quel délit j'ai
commis quoi j'ai beau chercher je le
vois pas quoi mais j'ai senti des
rapports aineux comme j'en ai rarement
vu quoi rarement vu avec des gens qui
des gens qui ont all jusqu'à ma voiture
pour me faire des doigts quoi avec des
doigs en disant tiens tes milliards
tiens tes milliards quoi c'est c'était
très surprenant quoi c'était très très
surprenant
[Musique]
j'espère que je me suis pas
TR tous les matchs maintenant on une
importance capitale même si on est
premier et qu'on a été premier tout le
long du du championnat on a entre
guillemets que 7 points d'avance sur le
second pour la montée en Top 14 il y a
que deux clubs qui montent le premier
est promu d'office et après entre le 2e
le 3e le 4e et le 5e il y a une
demi-finale et une finale et celui qui
remporte la finale monte donc tout
l'objectif est d'être premier pour pas
avoir à disputer deux matchs de
plus lorsque l'équipe se déplace à
l'extérieur les Fada et les mordus
vivent le match à distance depuis la
banane QG des
supporters on n compare souvent j'aime
pas trop ça mais aux supporteurs de l'OM
mais c'est vrai que la comparaison au
niveau de la passion est pas fusse quoi
on vit on vit la même chose nous la même
passion pour notre équipe que ce que les
supporters de Marsel
pour l'année dernière l'année dernière
on nait pas une équipe cette année moi
je P si qu'on a une équipe l'année
dernière on avait on avait une
coellation de star qui ne jouait pas en
équipe euh et bon on sait que que le
sport le rugby est un sport collectif
tout et que si si on a pas de cohésion
si joue pas avec un esprit d'équipe on
peut pas s'en sortir moi je pense que
cette année en dehors du fait qu'on
qu'on a des grands joueurs il y a un
esprit collectif et il y a une équipe
c'est la grosse différence de cette
année c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on est
[Musique]
premierin c'est normal personne nime
quand son équipe perd et là nous encore
moins qu on revoit vraiment le le Top 14
qui nous tend les bras il se laisse
désirer en
fait on s'ute un peu mais bon conforme à
ce qu'on
attendait gros combat devant bon on on n
pas passé loin je pense que que c'était
que c'était faisable mais bon on est un
peu retomberé dans not travers on a fait
beaucoup de
fautes voilà on pas eu cche quoi fait je
le pas trop mais je suis malade je je
pense que j'ai mal dormi cette
nuit jusqu'à la fin de la saison ça va
se ça pas se jouer à grandchose donc à
chaque fois ce sont des petits moments
de tuer le championnat qu'on laisse
passer et on va se ranger les onles
jusqu'à la fin rev rev sur nous donc on
va avoir un énorme match ici euh dans 3
semaines puisqu'on reçoit le Racing je
pense que la que la montée va se jouer
là quoi donc euh ça va être quelque
chose de grandiose ici je
pense et qu'on gag 15 à
1 bon moi j'étais vierge de toute
relation avec le passé de ce club donc
j'ai mis mes méthodes et mes concepts à
moi quoi et j'ai pas respecté
grand-chose c'est vrai mais je pouvais
pas faire autrement parce que sinon
c'était pas c'était pas gérable sur le
passé était trop lourd et puis petit à
petit j'essaie de retrouver la mémoire
de ce club parce qu'elle est importante
et qu'il y a des gens il y a des gens
très bien qui ont construit ce club et
que et que c'est vrai que si j'avais pas
si j'avais pas ce passer il y a beaucoup
de choses que j'aurais pas pu
faire avec l'histoire de club la culture
de de touulon c'est vrai que c'est un
pas peu particulier parce que c'est vrai
qu' à l'époque il y avait une grosses
pagardes de peut-être de autre niveau je
sais pas mais c'est rentré dans les
jeunes la l'gende de tulon et c'est vrai
qu'on est connu un peu pour ça mais
aussi pour avoir un pack très dur très
vaillant avoir les guerriers 15
guerriers sur le terrain ça ça fait
partie de notre esprit et je pense que
ça continue quand même même si pas mal
d'étrangers qui sont là on essaie de
dans le vesti par exemple les anciens ma
les anciens photos des grands joueurs
qui ont joué avec le muget et c'est
important pour que on peu essayer de
transférer cette passion cette coutur au
joueurs qui viennent de loin et en plus
on est dans le sudest de la France on
est le seul grand club fort dans la
région tous les autres clubs sont
presque tous les autres CLS sont dans le
Sud-Ouest alors ça on est un peu à part
par rapport aux autres aussi et
peut-être ça ça nous donne aussi un peti
particularité
[Musique]
Toulon avec beaucoup de modestie
d'humilité a demandé à à à Toulouse
d'être Parin de pour adopter les mêmes
couleurs queeux et d'être au départ
encadré par cette équipe par par ce ce
club du Stade Toulousain afin de afin de
progresser plus rapidement c'est ce qui
a été fait et puis peut-être que l'élève
a dépassé le maître en 31 puisque Toulon
a été champion et queensuite on a
retrouvé des parcours un peu parallèles
alors Toulouse qui s'est un peu éteint
au moment où dans la période de 68 à 71
Toulon était Toulon et béziier étaient à
l'apogé de de de leur euh de leur
performance avec l'arrivée comme
entraîneur de André Herrero et de Daniel
Herrero on a eu une période faste
formidable entre 1984 et et 1992 où on
fait euh on fait finale demi-finale euh
chaque année et où on a deux titres de
champion de France un en 87 un 92 mais
ensuite Toulouse a très bien négocié
l'arrivée du professionnalisme alors que
Toulon a stagné quand on stagne c'est le
début de la régression et bon on est en
train de rattraper le retard le retard
est considérable MAOL rest très très
longtemps inviolé comment on dirait mais
le jour de temps en temps il y avait une
équipe qui venait se régaler
ici on rappelle en Coupe de France BL
Balma Balma je crois est venu nous
battre ici bon c'était la coupe per
Pimpin qu'on jouit mais bon ça fait rien
perd la maillole c'était interdit on
était très en colère quoi par contre eu
ils ont fait la BR 15 jours il y avait
toute une grande mixité sociale qui
faisait que lorsqu'on portait un maillot
qu'on mettait un maillot on devenait
tous pareil quoi c'est ce maillot ce
maillot faisait nous rendrait nous rend
des frères et ça c'est très très beau
parce que tous les horizons qui soient
sociaux culturels était différent et ça
nous enrichissz tous et si j'avais un
regret à formuler c'est celui-ci quoi
que dans dans dans dans cette
installation où il faut aujourd'hui
produire un spectacle ce spectacle c'est
ça demande encore plus d'effort c'est
vrai qu'on va réduire on va réduire tout
ça pour pour le faire disparaître et
nous notre grande force c'était celle-là
quoi de de nous réunir de nous retrouver
surtout d'échanger d'apprendre à se
connaître parce que sans le rugby
j'aurais peut-être jamais dans mon mon
milieu mon milieu ne m'aurait jamais
amené à croiser des des médecins des
magistrats des agriculteurs des
commerçants et des gens de de de tous
les horizons et ça ça c'est la la grande
richesse mon premier métier ça a été
chauffeur poour moi je me levais à 6h le
matin pour aller travailler je rentrais
le soir à 5h après le boulot ou 6h je
prenais mon sac du Rubby je repartais
pour aller à l'entraînement c'est la vie
qu'on avait avant quoi donc c'était tout
à fait normal je ve dire on avait une
petite Prume de match comme ça quand on
jouait et puis c fini mais c'est vrai
que au départ il faut pas oublier un
truc c'est que tous les joueurs qui ont
joué au rugby même avant on y jouit
surtout par plaisir parce qu'on aimait
ce sport là et c'est vrai que le fait
qu'il soit devenu professionnel moi
j'entends devant maintenant des gamins
dire mais moi je veux être ban et c'est
vrai que je tite un peu des fois parce
que parce que c'est vrai que nous en
tant que gamin ou même plus grand on n
jamais pensé même moi le premier j'ai
jamais pensé en faire un jour mon métier
puisque ça pouvait pas l'être vu que
c'était dit un sport amateur le passé
m'intéresse pas Mo je dans l'édition je
garde pas les bouquins que j'édite les
seul qui m'intéressent c'est ceux que
j'ai édité ce qui est mort est mort je
veux dire
donc ce que j'ai gardé c'est je respecte
le club je respecte les anciens puisque
que dès que je vois un ancien c'est moi
qui veux lui dire bonjour j'estime que
c'est mon devoir euh mais ensuite moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est l'avenir du club
le passé je vais pas le refaire je donc
je me suis pas vraiment souci soucié de
ça je prre chose que j'ai fait c'est
j'ai à peu près viré tout le monde quoi
j'ai fait un grand vide et ce qui
s'était jamais fait parce qu'il y avait
besoin dans un premier temps de faire ce
grand vide quoi donc ben difficultés où
tout le temps je me suis fait passer
pour un
opportuniste quelqu'un qui connaissait
rien au rugby qui recrutait des
mercenaires qui venait ici pour faire
son image pour se faire sa pub quoi avec
5 million d'euros que j'ai mis dans le
club je pis me payer une campagne
d'affichage 4 par 3 sur tous les murs de
France et quelques spots publicitaires
sur TF1 quoi ou d'autres
chaînes moi je pense qu'il faut
considérer l'arrivée de ces je de ces
joueurs expérimentés étrangers comme une
période de transition permettant au club
de de de s'asseoir à l'équipe première
de s'asseoir en Top 14 et en plus et
après l'incorporation de jeunes de
qualité de plus en plus important va
permettre au club à l'équipe première de
retrouver cette ce creuser de de jeunes
joueurs de qualité je dis pas qu'on aura
plus besoin de joueurs étranger ou de
joueurs venant d'autres régions
mais ça coûtera quand même moins cher au
club de d'avoir de former les joueurs et
de les conserver moi je resterai pour
pour aider ces clubs pour qu'il se
pérénisent en Top 14 mais il faut du
temps et moi j'ai pas le temps je suis
en CDD dans le rugby j'ai beaucoup de
choses à faire à côté je suis un
accident de parcours du RCT et euh je
m'en irai en faisant beaucoup moins de
bruit que ce que ce que j'en ai fait en
arrivant quoi mais euh chaque jour me me
me rapproche de ce de de ce départ et et
euh c'est quelqu'un d'autre qu'il fera
mais bon si le club y arrive il faudra
qu'il se souvienne qui à un moment donné
il y a quelqu'un qui a créé le
professionnalisme à Toulon quoi voilà le
club est suspendu quand même à la
décision de Monsieur boudgéal le jour où
il arrête là pour le moment s'il arrête
rapidement le club est mort donc donc il
faut il faut il faut le savoir et c'est
pour ça que je dis qu'on est du j'aurai
une participation un investissement
durant la saison qui pourra pas être le
même que cette année voilà parce que
j'ai j'ai d'autres rêve ailleurs aussi
et puis c'est le rugby c'estf c'est
c'est usant quoi c'est une vraie
souffrance et ça fait vraiment mal pr
des deux c'est les résultats qui compent
donc il y a les résultats à l'extérieur
les points de bonus il y a tout il y a
tout qui compte là on est premier il
reste 6 matchs et on va pas on va pas
crier on va pas aller au scandale quand
même et Monsieur bougellal c'est vrai
que bon avec le bonheur qu'il a pour
amour pour le club pour tout ce qu'il
investit personnellement humainement
parlant moi je dis c'est beau ce qu'il a
fait cette année je pense qu'il a pas on
n pas la reconnaissance quoi il mérite
mieux quoi cet homme mérite mieux et ça
doit le ça doit le je sais pas ça doit
le blesser dans sa chair quoi si on
avait pas lui je qui moi je veux savoir
qui c'est qui pourrait faire aussi bien
que lui sur le plan du terrain du
sportif tout ce qu'il a créé quoi mon
expérience toulonaise la pro des deux
c'était un championnat c'était le le
mouroir du rugby français dire les clubs
qui de PR des deux ils jouaient pas tous
ave j'ai l'impression avec la même
couleur de chaussettes ou de short dans
la même équipe et
et depuis 2 ans mais c'est devenu c'est
devenu quelque chose de différent mais
par contre Ben a de il y a deux écoles
quoi il y a il y a il y a des niveaux
trop différent encore parce qu'il y a
des il y a des clubs qui sont les les
clubs du Top 14 de demain parce que la
géographie du rugby est en train de
beaucoup changer et donc des clubs
d'aujourd'hui en pro des deux son seront
dans le Top 14 demain et donc se donne
des moyens aujourd'hui qu' a des clubs
qui sont en pro des deux et qu' moins
moyen et qui qui utilise un rugby plus
plus restrictif et peut-être plus
agressif et qui compense leur manque de
leur manque de technicité par par de la
tricherie par par de l'agressivité
malsine quoi
et donc ça fait des écarts je pense
cette année c'était peut-être peêtre une
erreur que de mettre des joueurs du
niveau de gregane ou de Matfield pr des
deux quoi parce que c'était pas leur
c'était pas leur rugby quoi c'est un
rugby différent quoi ils sont c'est pas
c'est pas un rugby il y a une partie de
d'équipe qui ont rugby de voyou quoi
contre nous parce que parce que c'est la
seule façon de des fois de d'éviter de
de prendre de prendre une défaite parce
que parce que rugby pur ils vont pas
s'en sortir ils le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
savent ce que c'est bien avec moi c'est
que il n'a pas peur de parler des fois
c'est c'est bien des fois c'est pas bien
mais bon c'est son Doig aussi il a mis
beaucoup d'argent mais aussi parce que
s'il voit pas le sil voit les choses qui
sont pas bien il a
dit avec cette passion avec son argent
avec son ambition qui est très important
parce qu'il est très ambitieux dans sa
vie il est pasti de rien m il a beaucoup
il essaie de aussi de transférer ça au
joueurs parce que les joueurs ici je
pense qu'ils peuvent pas se plainre non
plus il fait beau il y a T comme
entraîneur euh il y a les étrangers il y
a les Français il g bien la vie on jou
devant stade plein les
weekend de toute évidence nous
travaillons pour
mour c'est lui qui nous a tous amené ici
il a fait du bon boulot pour ramener le
club à la place où il doit
être il travaille
énormément à cause du milieu d'où il
vient il sait ce que c'est que de
travailler dur et
fort pour toutes ces raisons tout le
monde peut être fier très
fier grâce à tout ce qu'il a fait il a
vraiment élevé le
club et en fait on a tous à espérer que
son enthousiasme durera
longtemps le Président il a amené à
Toulon des grands noms du
rugby
alors quelquefois je ne les trouve pas
aussi brillant que leur nom
l'indiquerait
mais malgré cela il a quand même réussi
à monter une équipe pour ce club le MO
qu'on puisse dire c'est qu'elle tienent
la route alors les HES chagrines vont me
parler d'argent moi j'en parlerai pas
parce que nous savons très bien que
aujourd'hui à la clé de tout succès il y
a des mises financières importantes le
Président il se bat il se bat pour qu'il
est vrai c'est budget jusqu'à présard il
y
arrive tout le monde me disait ouais
mais tu sais les grandes entreprises
c'est toujours Paris ils vont investir
sur Paris et tout donc moi j'aiessayé de
me dire je vais être encore plus fort
que Paris je vais avoir une image
mondiale et donc aujourd'hui le RCT est
le club français le mieux représenté
dans le monde on est le plus connu en
Nouvelle-Zélande en Australie en Afrique
du Sud de par les joueurs qu'on a et les
médias de tous ces pays qui viennent
chez nous ce qui veut dire qu'on est
aujourd'hui le seul capable d'accueillir
des partenaires qui recherchent une
image mondiale et donc j'ai je suis allé
au-delà de Paris quoi c'est ce que j'ai
voulu faire pour mon club une imag
international rarement un club et de pro
des deux aura autant été médiatisé que
tout l'on il aura suscité autant de
[Musique]
passion changement d'époque changement
de style à l'époque du rugby business
pour chaque joueur embauché ce sont des
milliers de maillots qui se vendent
depuis maintenant à peu près 2 ans
depuis que que président a repris en
main le club ça marche plutôt pas
mal on avait une toute petite boutique
dans dans la tribune du stade mais alors
quelque chose de 20 m² c'était pas très
grand mais quand le quand le président
est arrivé il a insoufflé ins soufflé
une nouvelle dynamique il a amené sa
politique d'entreprise au club et et
derrière on on s'est développé derrière
on a vite on a vite ouvert une boutique
donc celle-ci en octobre octobre 2006 on
a les cravates les ballons on a les
fanons les autocollants donc toute cette
gamme de produits dérivés qui marche
vraiment très
fort Tana Umaga ça a été vraiment le le
le joueur qui a eu le plus d'impact au
niveau produit dérivés au niveau du club
puisque ça a été le premier c'est un
personnage mythique dans le monde du
rugby il a une
personnalité il a du
charisme à l'image de toute c'est omaga
aujourd'hui c'est clair c'est omaga il v
il vend plus que les joueurs quoi il v
plus que les joueurs il y a c'est c'est
l'emblème de la ville quoi je veux dire
je vois même et puis même à l'extérieur
quand on se déplace il signe plus de
photos il fait plus d'autographes que il
prend plus de photos que les que tous
les que même les champions du monde qui
sort dans notre équipe quoi c'est Umaga
c'est il a un côté magique il a un
personnage il a une gueule il respire
quelque chose quoi je veux dire il a une
âme et les gens ils sont très sensiés en
plus c'est black et c'était le meilleur
joueur du
[Musique]
monde
mais il est évident que c'était aussi un
cout énorme pour pour mettre en
éclairage sur T dans le monde après que
céta un coup gagnant à tous les niveau
parce que sportivement ça ét parfaitous
fait gagner les
match et ensuite est tombé amoureux de
la ville il a souhaité il a souité
relever le défi avec moi
[Musique]
quoi pour moi le but principal c'est
d'amener le rugby tlon vers le Top
14 c'est ce qui nous donne de la force
tout au long de la route savoir qu'un
club si fier avec une si grande histoire
avec tant de supporters a une chance
d'arriver dans le Top 14 C année c'est
énorme non seulement pour le club mais
pour la ville
elle-même on célèbre les 100 ans du club
et il risque d'exister encore un siècle
de plus après nous en fait nous aurons
participé à le garder
[Musique]
vivant
le weekend le stade nous appartient plus
bien que la semaine nous appartienne pas
non plus mais bon on se l'approprie un
peu on le bichonne tellement
que que c'est le NRE quo mais le weekend
c'est fini on le récupère le lundi dans
un sal état souvent mais après en 3
jours il est
[Applaudissements]
neuf
allez on d'aller
droit l'objectif de la saison l'accès au
Top 14 semble apporter deain et à Toulon
chaque rencontre se joue à guich
ferm to
14 pas les
deminal trs
bien je
pmeonag
chudore maisag je
à Toulon il y a une espèce de fatalité
de ville difficile de ville pour réussir
il faut il faut quitter la ville il faut
monter à Paris il faut aller à
l'étranger et si on monte à Top 14 c'est
cette fatalité là que je crois qu'on va
qu'on va effacer les gens vont se dire
de tout tout est possible est
[Musique]
possible
h
[Applaudissements]
en jouant plus simplement on peut en
mettre beaucoup plus quoi on peut
prendre un bonus offensif bon cela dit
maintenant c'est plus très important
quoi ce qui est important c'est qu'il
reste 6 matchs il nous en reste trois à
gagner à Mayol pour être en Top 14 ça
c'est chose qui est importante la
manière on s'en fout un peu il y a plus
que le résultat qui compte on a battu à
jeun la manière c'est important en début
de saison parce que ça permet de se
régler sur toute la saison don de
l'espoir mais à si journée de la fait on
s'en fout il y a que le
résultat
TR par rapport au début de pas peut-être
pas à tou l'on parce que c'était déjà
professionnel mais mais c'est vrai que
là on est vraiment rentré dans le monde
professionnel avec avec Tana avec avec
tous ces grands joueurs qui nous ont
rejoint cette année donc on a vraiment
touché du doigt cette année nous les
jeunes du club ce qui était le
professionnalisme dans le rugby donc
donc il y a y a beaucoup de travail il y
a beaucoup de rigueur et beaucoup de
précision et et ça change pas mal ouais
moi quand j'étais tout petit euh
j'allais au stade avec mon père tous les
dimanches euh je vibrais pour pour ce
club donc donc je me dis qu'un jour
j'arriverai à être sur sur la pelouse à
mettre les chaussettes le maillot le le
short du RCT donc donc la première fois
que j'ai pu rentrer avec l'équipe
première sur sur le terrain ça m'a fait
ça m'a fait chaud au
[Musique]
cœur les gars aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
pour s'amuser c'est pourendre du plaisir
prendre du plaisir ça veut dire jouer
sérieusement d'accord rugby si on joue
pas sérieusement on prend pas de plaisir
même là Mme si on est
nous ils aiment ils aiment Gregan ils
aiment Matfield ils aiment les noms un
peu des des joueurs qui les ont fait
rêver pendant la coupe du monde qui puis
du jour au lendemain ils se retrouvent
sur la même pelouse à MAOL chez eux quoi
quelque part parce que les min c'est
chez eux Mayol appartient à tous les
tlonais je pense qu'il les voit oui
voilà a des je enfants un peu un peu
rêveur donc on essaie de les prendre
aussi comme exemple dire voilà ben
regarde telle situation il a joué comme
ça c'est à valeur d'exemple et puis
c'est c'est très positif pourquoi pour
l' pour les jeunes mais aussi pour le
club en
général des fois j'essaie de me mettre
enin de me mettre à leur place quand
j'étais quand j'étais gosse aussi donc
c'est vrai que quand on voyait les
joueurs du RCT on était comme des fous
on voulait l'autographe on voulait la
photo donc je mets à leur place et je me
dis que que aussi peut-être ils ont
envie d'arriver d'arriver en équipe
promare et de jouer à Toulon donc donc
il faut passer du temps avec eux et de
pas prendre ça comme une comme une
contrainte au contraire au contraire du
jour au lendemain les min pensent qu'
vont pouvoir être pro donc il faut pas
aussi faut pas leur mentir leur dire que
être pro il y en a certains qui qui
arriveront mais que c'est au prix de de
de sacrifice et énormément de travail
joueur de rugby la carrière est très
limitée en en durée il faut vraiment
préparer son après il faut il faut
concilier les deux absolument quoi
lesquip on rêve tous d'
être voilà donc dev voir jouer ben c'est
un rêve hein tout le monde on essaie
tous de d'aller à leur hauteur de
s'améliorer allez
appuis course normale 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
encore dans tous les sens prenez un peu
plus il faut que la formation elle elle
tire vers le haut niveau qu' qu'on a des
jeunes qui sortent tous les tous les ans
pour venir alimenter notre équipe fagon
et puis aussi jeis dire c'est c'est
aussi c'est aussi de l'ordre de la de la
ville quoi de la viille c'est le rugby
et tout long c'est c'est c'est
inséparable quoi donc voilà les Minos
qui foulent la pelouse peut-être qu'ils
sont pas professionnels mais ils seront
dans les gradins ils vont supporter leur
club ils iront faire des actions pour le
rugby et ils ont un état d'esprit
Toulonnais et et du RCT donc c'est
véhiculer les valeurs du RCT c'est c'est
essentiel même si aujourd'hui le rugby a
évolué même s' a est professionnel même
si c'est un monde qui qui évolue à
dem000 à l'heure garder les valeurs
toulonaises c'est quand même c'est quand
même hyper important et c'est c'est ce
qui fait que Ben tout le monde se se se
sent bien dans ce club et se sent bien
dans ce
stade ça fait 10 fois que je dis tout le
terrain c'est tout le terrain
[Musique]
ouis le truc très très important on va
dire à l'URE d'aujourd'hui c'est de pas
de pas de pas se laisser griser parce
que euh maintenant c'est vrai qu'il y a
quand même pas mal d'argent au niveau de
au niveau du rugby même pour des jeunes
qui qui commencent c'est vrai qu'ils ont
un salaire assez important par rapport à
des jeunes de leur âge qui qui vont
rentrer dans un boulot on va dire
classique et et le tout c'est de pas se
Laer griser c'est de vraiment s'attacher
à avoir les pieds sur terre de manière à
à ce que de manière à surtout à savoir
que le jour où le rugby s'arrête euh et
ben la vie continue et souvent ben on
est obligé de travailler derrière super
public toute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
année c'est mon dernière année en France
et c'est mon derni année en tlon moi je
suis venu à 2005 directement à tlon de
l'Afrique du
[Musique]
Sud quand je suis venu pour la première
fois à Toulon j'étais dans l'équipe de
Dax on jouit contre eux et je me suis
dit j'ai vraiment envie de revenir et
maintenant habité ici avec ces joueurs
et cet entraîneurs ça représente un
parcours incroyable pour
moi je suis venu quand j'avais 20 ans
donc on peut dire que que j'étais encore
un gamin mais bon ça m'a donné l'école
de vie parce que quand je suis arrivé je
suis arrivé seul donc ça a été quand
même assez difficile de passer de passer
6 7 mois sans personnes sans ma famille
sans ma femme donc VO je pense que c
grande école de vie B milieu de sport
elle est assz assez cruel donc on peut
être là un an on pe 10 ans mais après il
peut AR blessure c'est fini donc moi je
me projette pas vraiment
[Musique]
la j'attends de pouvoir jouer dans le
Top 14 et le club l'attend aussi je
pense qu'on va y arriver le club va
monter et j'ai vraimentêtre en Top
14 moi je croyais que les gens Sud étai
beaucoup plus décontractés que que les
Européens en fait ils sont comme nous
ils sont très concentré les joueurs
savent que il vont avoir un combat
quoier c'est un combat on a une équipe
de joueurs prestigieux quoi et de tout
temps à Toulon on a eu des gens un peu
moins prestigieux mais mais très rudes
[Musique]
quoi
toujours sais que je veux venir en
France mais
avant je suis
ven on est t lo de la maison très très
loin vraiment comme chez nous on a une
pression énorme de la part du public et
de la V entière mais c'est la
vie
je meis dit peut-être que la ville ne va
pas s'identifier à cette équipe parce
qu'il y a beaucoup de d'origines
différentes et étrangères et une de mes
fiertés si on monte c'est que il y a une
identification à la ville à l'équipe
très forte de la ville ce qui veut dire
et là je reviens à 95 que en 95 la ville
avait un petit peu oublié son essence à
savoir l'ouverture vers le monde et que
là elle l'a retrouvé quoi en intégrant
tous ses étrangers entre guillemets
comme des
quoi c'est oui c'est incroyable
aujourd'hui je veux dire Oren Gregan
sont des toulonais pour les toulonais
quoi et et on parle plus d'étrangers si
ce sont tous des toulonis quoi et moi je
suis fier d'avoir contribué à
ça les gens sont spéciaux ici je pensais
que les supportes de Cape Town étaient
les meilleurs mais c'est vraiment
incroyable de jouer
ici ils sont un petit peu singlés ils
savent de quoi ils parlent ils aiment ce
sport ils sont vraiment derrière
nous la vie dans le Sud de France c'est
tranquille on se bien ici avec ma femme
et ma petit et ouais maintenant c'est
c'est comme ma famille ici
c'est si on vient en France le mec qui
vient dans le sud de le sud c'est
toujours on a toujours un petit peu
d'Afrique du Sud dans mon cœur mais
après 3 ans c'est maintenant c'est tout
long qui dans mon cœur et qui qui me
plaît le Toulon c'est c'est la ville de
rugby donc c'est la ville qui qui vit
pour le rugby qui qui don énormément
joueurs je pense que ça fait beaucoup ça
fait vraiment c'est quelque chose qu'on
trouve pas dans les dans les autres
villes ou si on le trouve c'est pas
c'est pas dans le même dans la même
folie c'est
pas c'est pas aussi chaleureux que ça
tout c'est c'est tout
c'est bien pour
bien le plus c'est que le moral de
beaucoup des T per
club
commeig
j vont vivre à T jamais vu et ça ils le
savent ça sera plus fort que tout ce
qu'ils ont vécu jusqu'à présent parce
qu'ils
ont et moi on a un point commun c'est
que dans les touons Toulon on est les
deux seuls je crois entendre la douleur
qu'il y a depuis quelques années il y a
de la douleur dans c'est Toulon Toulon
du public et je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
de joueurs qui l'ont entendu aussi ils
sont conscients que que ce qu'on peut
apporter à cette ville c'est ce qu'il y
a de plus beau quoi c'est le bonheur et
donner un sens à notre à notre histoire
depuis un an ou
deux j'ai vu une vraie passion ici et
c'est très positif pour
nous on a un vrai soutien de la foule
c'est très
agréable mais évidemment avec autant de
soutien et de passion viennent de
grandes responsabilités et une attente
énorme du public à nous d'arriver à
vivre
[Musique]
avec
je pense qu'on a largement sur sur le
papier un groupe exceptionnel quoi avec
des jeunes des nouveaux des anciens des
étrangers des stars et les jeunes qui
poussent derrière des maestries anésies
des chou des
Grimau c'est eu les star
montant c'est pas un champat qu'on peut
qu'on pourrait espérer avec ces joueurs
donc j'espère que si certains restent
l'année prochaine ils vivront une autre
image du rugby français et pas de rester
végét dans ce championnat de Pro de qui
qui est pénible quoi qui est pénible on
est attendu de partout rempl les stades
les équipes sont agressif dans le bon
sens du terme voir des fois dépasser les
limites mais malheureusement
malheureusement c'est le championnat pr
de qu'il faut respecter avec tous les
tous les problèmes qu'on peut avoir tous
les
weekends il faut absolument finir
premier avec les moyens que que notre
président a donné on peut pas se
permettre de finir second 3è ça commence
par La Rochelle là après il y a Narbonne
après il y a auac après il y a Lyon
après il monmars il a le métro c'est des
matchs importants c'est des matchs où là
ben on sent la fin du championnat ça y
est on boue et et on y est on va le
prendre le ticket pour le Top 14
[Musique]
j'espère il y a aujourd'hui l'espoir
qu'on suc dans la montée qu'on a qui met
beaucoup de pression parce qu'on a pas
le droit de le décevoir il y a cette C
espoir aussi si on est en Top 14 qu'on a
pas le droit de des savoir les gens
comprendrai pas ça sera encore plus
grave de faire ça que de pas monter quoi
donc effectivement ben il faut il faut
construire une
équipe et c'est je m'attelle à ça quoi
mais après c'est la course au budget
donc le but c'est d'avoir un des plus
gros budgets de France quoi et je pense
qu'à tout le mond peut le constituer et
ensuite avoir d'avoir de très gros
joueurs en plus et de garder tous nos
gros joueurs et intégrer nos meilleurs
jeunes qu'on a tous conservés petit à
petit dans cet effectif
quoi mon rêve c'était de monter en Top
14 pour l'instant j'ai pas de rêve en
Top 14 donc il faut que je m'en cré un
quoi et mais j'ai cette particularité
c'est que je fais pas de différence
entre mes rêves et mes
ambitions donc ça sera forcément très
haut
alors déroulement ben c'est levé très
tôt ce matin déplacement au bus ensuite
on attendu pararbonet pour midi donc on
arrive on partage avec eux le le repas
du midi et ensuite on fait un peu la
fête avec eux on assiste au match on
espère qu'on gagne et ensuite on reste
encore un peu avecor on voit les joueurs
et ensuite on rentre tranquillement à la
maison terrible CR de guerre parce
que alors les Fada c'est 880 des rant
750 ou
770 abonnés au club donc c'est vraiment
une grosse machine parce que
tout parce que
tout on est tour accueilli comme des
comme des rois on fait la fête avec les
supporters adverses donc c'est vraiment
peu de contrainte en fait c'est plus tu
t'amuses plus que tu tu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
contrôles il y a cette frustration ce
sentiment d'impuissance qui qui en
entreprise quand ça va pas bien on va
chercher des trucs des idées on se bouge
qu pour pour que ça aille mieux mais là
on peut rien faire quand on est sur le
terrain fais-moi les match c'est une
souffrance quoi je dire je il y a Mme il
y a même des essais que j'ai raté quoi
je me souvens l'année dernière à
colomier je me sentais pas capable de de
de voir les 5 premières minutes et donc
j'ai pas regardé les 5 minutes je su all
me planquer dans les toilettes que j'ai
dit un jour je ferai un guide des
toilettes des stades de France je les
connais toutes et je suis revenu au bout
de 5 minutes et donc je regarde le match
je le tableau d'affichage il y avait 7
à0 pour Toulon donc on avait marqué d'
prè et je l'avais pas vu et je le savais
même pas
quoi
à Toulon on continue de servir la messe
à Mayol seul stade en France en plein
centre-ville c'est le localarrangement
c'est en fait c'est le cœur du stade
quoi ici puisque puisque c'est le
magasin général du de la SSP du du du
club on habille les joueurs il y a de la
pharmacie il y a y a il y a tout ce
qu'on a besoin pour un match
pratiquement quoi avant on était on
était on était pas si professionnel que
ça quoi je veux dire que les joueurs ils
aent aucun souci avant de de rentrer sur
le terrain et de jouer il pensent qu'à
le qu'à leur
match j'ai mon emploi qui qui qui me
permet pas d'être là à plein temps mais
bon je passe quand même beaucoup de
temps
ici on est un peu dans l'ombre quoi mais
bon quand le quand quand l'équipe quand
l'équipe gagne et avec les résultats que
nous avons eu cette année bon évidemment
on est on est on est satisfait quoi
c'est la c'est c'est la grande
satisfaction quoi c'est la récompense
quoi voilà j'ai aussi la chance de
côtoyer des gens comme George ggan Anto
Oliver je veux dire c'est ininpiré pour
moi parlons
pas c'est du plaisir pour moi c'est pas
rien
d'autre bien sûr des fois il des moments
de tension même moi je suis avant les
matchs on dirait presque que je jouer
par
moment beaucoup dere dégage quelque
chose étrange
Mme j'ai vu des grands matchs ici des
grands
matchsu beaucoup de sueur de
sang c'est
dur les jouurs après le match pour
récupérer baign dans la glace je fais
venir tous les samedis grand bar de
glace et quand on rempl le bassin et
après le match pour faciliter la
récupération il se Baig dans la glace
Mme
l'hiver
demain c'est dir demain demain c'est pas
dans la poche mais presque sur le coup
des des 17h30 nous som en Top 14 c'est
je suis plus plus que
convaincu approchez-vous là s'il vous
plaît venez là
resserrez-vous que c'est pas un stade de
8000 places ici il y a 12500 places
c'est simple quand on s'aperçoit que
quelque chose ne va pas on intervient
tout de suite d'accord si vous
intervenez dans la dans les 15 20
secondes qui suivent de suite le
soufflet retombe la sécurité est un des
éléments de du match on doit veiller à
ce que les gens dans les tribunes ben
respectent justement l'esprit rugby
qu'on veut faire perdurer euh euh à
chaque match de la
saison
si on gagne ce sera sera un jour sera un
jour super comme il y a y a 3 ans parce
que bah on sera champion on sera en Top
14 on pourra on pourra partir à lon sans
pression si on
perd on on va continuer à se ronger les
ongles les portes vont ouvrir dans à peu
près demi-heure petit à petit les gens
vont s'installer l'ambiance va monter la
fête va va monter en puissance et bon
voilà puis à 18h30 coup d'envoi et c'est
parti
quoi je suis pas plus inquiet que ça
quoi maintenant je deviens un petit peu
il va se passer ce qui va se passer
voilà mais ça m'inquiète de pas être
inquié parce que j'aime bien j'ai j'ai
un stress positif en général
ouais le stress me donne l'impression de
contrôler les
choses on va voir mais bon là il y a
plus de il y a plus aucune certitude là
maintenant on verra bien ce qui se passe
il se passera ce qui se passera je veux
dire quand on sera mort depuis 2
millions d'années ça sera pas très
important de savoir si on a a gagné auss
on a perdu contre la MRO
RAC c'est comme si on monte dans un
avion pendant 8h et on se dit il peut se
ccher quoi il y a une chance sur sur
million mais ça veut dire une chance sur
de parce que
pas automatiquement le RAC va gagner il
y a pas d'incertitude sur ce
match pas
nombre Brant c'est une super ambiance à
on voulait aussi voir cette fête
là
t c'est la consécration de beaucoup
d'efforts de mourade et son équipe et
des joueurs donc c'est la montée directe
donc ça peut être
l'è populaire la joie
le puis nous bon c'est pas un match coup
pr c'estbitoire quoi qu'il en soit on
est qualifié pour les deminal qu'on va
jouer chez nous mais on vient avec la
ferme intention de vendre ch
notre
on a possibilité aujourd'hui
éventuellement de monter en Top 14 c'est
un match que j'attends depuis 2 ans mais
en face il a la plus redoutable des
équipes donc ça va être ça vare 80
minutes très
difficile c'est pas qui été pris par les
pompiers c'est pas ma
fille
[Musique]
est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais non
elle tombe pas il la reprend il la
reprend il a repris pas un
avant excusez-moi excusez-moi
excusez-moi la passion mais non mais ça
s'arrête au niveau du cri moi chez
moi il aura jamais il y avait un avant
sérieux ou
pas elle est pas tombé la BAL
estie avant fait ça tombe pas avant je
pense pas qu'il a quelqu'un depuis très
longtemps qui autant donn à son club
même pas niveau d'argent quoi mais je
crois qu' laissé ma santé dans ce club
j'ai laissé ma santé j'ai donné tout ce
que j'avais j'ai pas fait semblant avec
mes erreurs avec mon caractère avec avec
mes exubérances mais je don
j'ai toujours dit que je feris je
donnerai de mon mieux je sais pas si mon
mieux suffira je voulais montrer à ma
ville ce
que c'est qu'un enfant de la ville issu
de l'immigration si dire éta pouvait
faire et délivrer un message un peu plus
positif j'avais été assz marqué parce
qu'il s'est dépassé en 95 chez moi même
humilié et oui j'ai j'ai un message
j'avais un message par rapport à ça mais
bon maintenant je l'ai complètement
dépassé maintenant c'est j'ai mis 2 ans
de vie entre parenthèses avec un
objectif dans ma tête depuis 2 ans j'ai
fait abstraction de plein de choses dans
ma vie professionnelle dans ma vie de
famille avec une idée fixe qui est la
montée en Top
14 ça fait 2 ans que je vis pour pour
quelques
[Musique]
minutes énor c'est pas fini c'est pas
fini jamais connu ça dans la vie et je
suis un petit peu allé là aussi dans le
sport pour ça quand j'avais vu le match
de la montée touar je me souviens qu'à 5
minutes de la fin parce que le score
était fait j'ai vu le président champ de
l'époque les entraîneurs ils sautaient
ils s'en laassaient je me disais si là
ils vivent un truc au niveau émotion que
je connaîtrai jamais quoi parce que ça
doit ça rien à voir avec l'émotion qu'on
peut avoir sur un bestcellerire sur une
une rencontre avec un auteur où nous on
est le seul à savoir que quand il a un
truc on va pas rendormir dans la nuit
mais là c'est par rapport à ce que se
représente en terme de d'investissement
de travail de dispute avec ses copains
de de déception de d'espoir il là il
vivent 5 minutes
qui que très peu de gens peuvent
connaître quoi et je suis un peu allé
pour chercher ces 5 minutes quoi je sais
pas si je vais les vivre ces minutes je
les ai vécu des des centaines de fois
dans ma
tête et alors là c'est un peu
particulier parce que dans la vie il y a
eu il y a déjà eu un impossible qui
s'est produit quoi quand j'ai démarré
mon métier d'éditeur pour moi réussir
dans la vie et devenir éditeur c'était
quelque chose d' absolument impossible
c'était quelque chose qui était
forcément destiné aux autres quoi ça
venit du milieu donc jeenais qui était
pas un milieu très brillant et quand je
je me dis bon j'ai réussi quoi enfin je
pense avoir réussi dans la métier
c'était une vraie surprise quoi et là
pareil je suis persuadé que je monterai
jamais en Top 14 parce que c'est pas
quelque chose qui peut m'arriver à moi
et ça fait très bizarre de c'est dire
que
peut-être je vais avoir une seconde de
choses impossibles qui peut m'arriver
dans ma vie quoi c'est comme ça que je
le
[Applaudissements]
prends
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aprs vous en avez rêvé l' fait ça y est
c'est faitit c'est énorme il s'est passé
quelque chose
d'
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]